[Music]
disturbing new details about the dog
that died out in the heat yesterday
police say okobe tobina
left his dog hanging from a fence at the
apartment complex though an arrest
report from metro says he claimed his
dog had been missing and he didn't know
who did it but police say
surveillance footage tells a different
story they say it shows him walking to
the front of the complex around three in
the morning
and then walking back without the dog he
is facing an
animal torture charge the arrest report
also making it clear that the owner did
not do anything to prevent the puppy's
death
it's hard to to see why folks would do
things like this
but what we can focus on is putting out
that message that it's not okay
don't leave your children in your car
when it's hot don't leave your pets in
your car when it's hot
and certainly don't leave an animal
strung out on a fence
exposed to all the elements without
thinking that someone's going to call
and you're not going to pay the price
the report also says he had two
outstanding warrants for
previous weapon and drug related charges